president now it's abundantly clear that
we all agree that pollinators are
essential and that we need to protect
them and this is clear from everybody's
comments the Commission has recognized
the urgency and promptly answered the
cause of the European Parliament and of
the public to tackle the decline of
pollinators and we adopted the European
pollinators initiative which is an
ambitious framework that can address
this complex challenge it does
consolidate actions across European
Union policies and strengthen links
between them and to do this we consulted
broadly experts and stakeholders and
introduced new actions where gaps gaps
were identified now in the light of the
European Green Deal actions addressing
the main threats to pollinators do need
to be scaled up and made more effective
to measure the effects of policies and
measures however we also need a robust
monitoring system
for pollinators and the threats they
face I heard a lot of the questions are
carefully I agree it's crucial to look
at inputs the and the upcoming
evaluation of the pesticide legislation
we'll look at the issue of import
allowances and open this discussion the
Green Deal I heard this being mentioned
does in fact speak about reducing
pesticide it says we will reduce the
risk and use of pesticides significantly
and the farm to fork strategy which as
you all know will be presented hopefully
in the spring will be more specific
about specific targets
additionally the Commission has taken
decisive action to ban and restrict the
use of neonicotinoids to are no longer
approved one cannot be used outdoor and
the Commission will be proposing not to
renew the approval of a fourth one and
it is supporting the use of low-risk and
non chemical pesticides now concerning I
think there was a question on emergency
authorizations we have increased
scrutiny of these including proposing
decisions preventing two countries from
granting contested authorizations
furthermore the Commission will continue
supporting
member states to ensure the sustainable
use of pesticides and the Commission
will be presenting the findings of the
refit evaluation of the pesticides
regulation and the second report on the
implementation of the sustainable use
directive early in 2020 and finally I
agree that having an ambitious strategy
plan on the C ap is very important in
order to deliver our own ambitions now
let me out be absolutely clear the
Commission is determined to coordinate
and steer a decisive European Union
action to stop and reverse pollinator
decline however the success of this
initiative will critically depend on
strong engagement of all stakeholders in
its implementation Member States will
have an indispensable role in deployment
of effective actions and monitoring
systems on the ground and we look
forward to the European Parliament
strong endorsement of this initiative
and the crucial role of Member States in
its implementation for our well-being I
welcome this discussion today on this
very important topic it is clear that
the current efforts on pollinators
protection they are not sufficient we
need to have more holistic and
coordinated approach on this issue and
there is broad support in the council to
increase the environmental ambition in
the CIP the Common Agricultural Policy
reform of course taking into account the
situation of our farmers
moreover the relevant EU measures have
to be stronger and probably implemented
I'm therefore look
in forward to the new commission
strategy which will hopefully address
the weaknesses of the current EU
policies and will be accompanied by
appropriate monitoring and enforcement
mechanisms to improve their technique
Ness thank you very much for this
important discussion is the president
ketose grazie Mille
Anitra communica very cheveux tuna
propose Adira soluciones a conclusion la
discusión e de parte de la commissioner
burrell ambiente la gente Publica la
cigarettes alimentary the discussion
acusaciones Val Jura nella geometry
domani